in previous videos we introduced the
idea of a production function that takes
in a bunch of inputs let's call this
input 1 input 2 input 3
and that based on how much of these
various inputs you have your production
function can give you your output
in this video we're going to constrain
all of the inputs but one to really take
it down to how does our output vary as a
function of one input and as we do that
we're going to be able to understand
these ideas of total product marginal
product and average product so to give
you a tangible example let's say that we
are running an ice cream factory and we
care about how much our ice cream
production per day varies as a function
of the number of people working in the
factory so let me write this down so per
day
ice cream
production
and so let me make a table here
so in
my our first column
i am going to put our labor which is you
could use the input that we're going to
see how does that drive output so i will
put labor
so you could view this as workers per
day
workers
and we're going to see how our output
varies whether we have zero workers one
worker per day two workers per day or
three workers per day now our next
column would just be our output and
we'll say that's our total product as a
function of labor tp standing for total
product and let's say that we know
if we have zero people working in our
ice cream factory well then we're going
to produce zero gallons of ice cream and
let's just assume that this is this our
output is in
gallons and it's gallons per day if we
have one worker at our factory well then
we're going to be able to produce 10
gallons a day if we have two workers at
our factory we're going to produce 18
gallons a day and if we have three
workers at our factory let's say we can
produce 24 gallons a day fair enough
now i'm going to introduce an idea and
you've seen this word marginal perhaps
at other times in your life i'm going to
introduce marginal product of labor and
the way to think about marginal that's
how much for every increment of one
thing how much more of the other thing
do you get so here our marginal product
of labor says for each incremental unit
of labor for each incremental person
working there per day how much more how
many more gallons of ice cream am i
producing
so
my marginal product of labor when i go
from zero to one workers i'm able to
produce 10
more gallons from that first worker now
what about when i go from one worker to
two workers
well then i go from 10 to 18 gallons so
that second person gets me an
incremental
eight gallons per day
and then as i go from two people working
there to three people working there well
my total product goes up by six so my
marginal product of labor for that third
worker is going to be
six
now there's something interesting that
you're immediately seeing here
and this is actually pretty typical is
that your marginal product of labor will
oftentimes go down the more and more
people that you add and you might say
why is that the case
well they're just not going to be quite
as productive that second person might
be waiting while the first person is
using the mixer and that third person is
going to be waiting while the first
person and the second person maybe
they're using the restroom or something
and the third person has to go and you
can imagine you had four or five six at
some point you're not even able to fit
people into the factory and so you're
you're going to have what's known as a
diminishing marginal return and you see
that right over here as you're adding
more and more labor your marginal return
is getting smaller and smaller so this
is a diminishing marginal return
now the last concept i'm going to
introduce you to in this video is that
of average product and this is average
product as a function of labor so ap for
average product
and all that is is our total product
divided by our labor so over here when
we have one worker our total product is
10 gallons and we're going to divide
that by one worker so our average
product per worker is going to be 10
gallons now when we have two people
working per day and we're producing 18
gallons today per day our average
product as a function of labor is going
to be 18 divided by 2 which is going to
be 9 gallons per worker per day on
average
and then in this last situation it's
going to be 24 divided by 3 which is 8
gallons per worker per day on average
and you can see this visually as well i
can draw this on a curve
let me do that
so
if on our horizontal axis
i have our labor units which is workers
per day so one
two
and three so this is labor right over
here and our vertical axis i'll have our
total output
so total product i could say so let's
say that's 10
20. let's say that is 30 right over
there
well
this first one right over here when we
have one person working in the factory
we produce 10 gallons per day
and this is total product right over
here when we have two people working in
our factory we produce 18 gallons a day
so it's going to be just like that
and notice
the slope has gone down a little bit
we have a certain slope here but it's a
little less deep there and that
steepness of that line or of that curve
that tells you about the marginal
product so it's a little bit less deep
so our marginal product of labor has
gone down a little bit we're having
diminishing marginal returns and then
last but not least
when we have three people working we're
able to produce 24 so 3 and 24 might be
right over there and once again we can
see our diminishing returns it gets even
a little bit flatter
we go from zero to one
we added plus ten and you can see that
there in the marginal product of labor
and then as we add one more person it
goes plus eight and then we add another
person it goes plus six so in general if
you see total product as a function of
labor or total output as a function of
labor and the curve is getting less and
less and less steve well that tells you
that your marginal product is going
lower and lower and you're getting
diminishing marginal returns